when I was probably nine
um I worked on a film called Just Cause
and Lawrence Fishburne was in it and we
were traveling somewhere for the film we
were all on a plane and I trapped I
passed him in the in the uh aisle and he
said to me hey let me ask you a question
do you want to be an actor or do you
want to be a movie star
um
and you know in my mind I I didn't
really know I didn't know what what he
meant exactly I felt like you know you
can be both right I mean you can be both
what he was saying to me is like are you
here to do the work
um and you know I I internalized that if
your end goal is just to be a movie star
well you know that's one that's
different than acting